So the project of the phenomenology of spirit
is to determine what knowledge is or what knowing is.
And the reason that we want to do that
is to determine whether knowledge of the absolute
is possible or whether, as Kant argued in the first critique,
the absolute lies beyond the limits, at least,
of theoretical knowledge we're going to be in.
Now, what the absolute is for Hegel
is something that it's going to take us a while to see.
And there's kind of no, I don't think
it's probably helpful to say the Hegelian formula of what
the absolute idea is before we get there.
So the short version is it's what
Hegel will call the absolute idea at the end of the logic.
Before we get there, you can think of it as God.
A little bit better, you can think of it as Spinoza's God.
A little bit better, you can think of it
as the unconditioned in Kant.
And even better than that would be
if you thought of it as neither subjective, so neither
a mind nor nature, but something that's both.
What the hell that means, you'll see.
So Hegel then discusses what I call
the meta-epistemological problem, a problem about how
we determine what the correct epistemology is,
what the correct account of what knowing is.
And the problem is, how do we decide,
not just between different knowledge claims,
but between different epistemologies?
So if I claim to know that Fargo is
the capital of North Dakota, and you claim that I don't know
that because it's false, but we share the same epistemology,
namely looking at an atlas, then that's not a big problem.
But if you and I have different epistemologies,
and I claim I know that God exists
on the basis of immediate religious state,
then you say, well, you couldn't know whether God exists,
because the proposition God exists appears nowhere
in natural science.
Well, first of all, we both have really shitty epistemologies.
But secondly, and arguably the second one
is worse than the first, there's no way
to adjudicate which of us has the correct conception
of knowledge on the basis of which we could then
adjudicate who knows what they claim to be.
So Hegel relates this to the problem of the criterion,
which was originally formulated by sextus empiricus
in the outlines of purinism.
And the problem of the criterion takes the form of a dilemma.
Either we have some can someone makes a knowledge claim,
and they have a certain conception of knowledge.
They claim to know that God exists
on the basis of immediate religious faith.
We either apply their own conception of knowledge,
in which case trivially, their knowledge claim
is going to be vindicated.
So if we either, for each person's
conception of knowledge, we simply apply it to itself,
everyone's going to pass that task.
The other possibility is that we apply
a different conception of knowledge.
The problem with that is that looks question made.
Someone says, I know that God exists
on the basis of immediate religious faith.
And then I say, well, that epistemology
doesn't justify that knowledge claim,
because that epistemology fails the criterion
of my epistemology.
Namely, you know those and only those things
that appear as propositions in empirical natural science.
I've banked the question against the person
who has a different criterion of knowledge
or a different conception of what knowledge is.
So Hegel's solution is a version of the first one,
where we apply some conception of knowledge to itself.
But the difference is he thinks that these conceptions
of knowledge, or concepts, as he calls them
in the phenomenology, typically do not agree with themselves.
When you look at them, what you see
is their conception of knowledge and their conception
of the object of knowledge don't agree.
And now you might think that's very artificial.
But actually, if you look at a lot of epistemology,
certainly in the history of philosophy,
you'll find it is very often these problems do arise.
If you read Locke, it's very unclear how Locke
thinks he knows all of the things he thinks he knows,
because he thinks he knows everything
he knows through sensation, ultimately.
But that he claims to know that God exists,
that there are substances with powers that are extended,
or at least have primary qualities that
resemble our ideas of them.
And it's very unclear from Locke how he could know any
of the things he claims to know.
Likewise, the My Little Toy epistemology,
the person who knows only the propositions enumerated
in the empirical natural sciences, which
here's one of the propositions.
Here's a proposition that occurs nowhere
in empirical natural science.
You know all and only those things
that are stated in the empirical natural science.
But their own epistemology, they don't
know what they claim to know.
So Hegel's solution, which is to examine
the internal coherence of these concepts of knowledge,
is more productive than it might at first appear.
So what Hegel is going to then engage in
is an imminent or internal critique
of various conceptions of knowledge,
or as he calls them, forms or shapes of consciousness.
Gestadens büliskes.
Now they're imminent because we are not
going to impose our own criteria of knowledge
on these shapes of consciousness.
We're going to examine them purely internally
and see whether their conception of knowledge
matches their conception of the object of knowledge.
That is to say, whether you could
know, according to their conception of what knowledge
is, the object of knowledge according to their conception
of the object of knowledge.
Now Hegel adopts for expository or analytic purposes
a kind of abstract model of what consciousness is.
And that is we have consciousness,
we have an object, which we call the in itself,
because it isn't reducible to its being for consciousness,
and we have the relationship of that object for consciousness,
how it is for consciousness, which
is another way of describing it.
Now a few comments about this.
One, you might say, but wait, aren't there
conceptions of knowledge on which consciousness knows itself?
Absolutely.
But we're going to unfold those in the course
of the phenomenon.
So we start with what Hegel thinks
of as the most immediate natural conception of knowledge, one
in which you know something that is distinct from
and irreducible to your knowledge of it.
That's what Hegel characterizes as consciousness.
Now the question is going to be, does this relation,
as consciousness conceive of it, constitute knowledge
of this object as consciousness conceives it?
Another question is, where are these conceptions coming from?
They're coming from consciousness itself.
Or as Hegel will say, consciousness
is the concept of itself.
Consciousness has a conception of it.
That means in the ordinary sense of self-consciousness,
consciousness is self-conscious from the beginning
of the phenomenon.
In the ordinary sense of not only knowing objects,
but also having some conception of what you're
doing in knowing objects, who you are,
what knowledge is, what the object is,
self-consciousness is present from the very beginning.
Self-consciousness in Hegel's conception,
in the technical sense in which it emerges in the phenomenology,
refers to review on which what knowledge fundamentally
is, is self-consciousness, so that consciousness doesn't
fundamentally know an object.
It knows itself knowing an object.
So that we're not going to get to in this case.
You don't think that somehow consciousness
has no conception of itself.
Because if it did from the first page of the phenomenology,
the project would fail.
If this doesn't match this as consciousness conceives of it,
then this is not a way of knowing this
as consciousness conceives of it,
and this shape of consciousness contradicts it.
But now if this shape of consciousness contradicts itself,
the result is not what Hegel calls an abstract negation.
That is to say, we just give up on knowledge.
The result is what Hegel calls a determinate negation.
Or that is to say, a new shape of consciousness, which
is determinately, specifically, not this shape of consciousness.
And the new shape of consciousness,
if this is object one, object two
is the being of object one for consciousness.
So the idea is we have some conception of knowing.
We have some conception of the object of knowledge.
That turns out not to be a way of knowing that object.
So then what results from that is not, well,
let's just give up on knowing.
But oh, what we can know is objects
insofar as they can be for consciousness in this way.
And a very good example of this is,
in the beginning of the Transcendent of Critique of Pure
Reason, Kant's first view, this is
a kind of slightly hokey, big alien reading
of the beginning of the Critique of Pure Reason,
you could think of the first shape of consciousness
in the Critique of Pure Reason as transcendental realism.
What we know is things in themselves,
totally mind-dependent objects, and we
know them in their mind-dependent nature.
And we know them through their effects upon our sensibility.
And then the argument of the first critique
very early on in the Transcendental Aesthetic
is that that way of knowing, sensible cognition,
is not a way of knowing things in themselves.
So then the second shape of consciousness,
Kant's own view, Transcendental Idealism,
is we know the being of consciousness
of the first object for consciousness.
What we know is not things in themselves
via sensory cognition.
We know the being of them for sensory cognition.
That is to say, their appearance is sensory cognition.
So the second object is the being of the first object
for consciousness.
In this case, the appearing of things in themselves
to sensory cognition.
That's just an illustration.
So now we have a conception of how the phenomenology moves.
That is to say, how we go from one shape of consciousness
to the next.
A complete account would have to also include
an account of where we start.
But we're going to spend a lot of today talking about that.
So I'm going to bracket that for now.
Where does the phenomenology end?
The phenomenology will end.
Oh, we have some math.
All right.
The phenomenology will end when the relation of, let's say,
consciousness, although it won't be called consciousness
anymore, for reasons I'll go into,
or the relation of consciousness to the in itself,
where these things are so tightly identified
that no possible gap between being for itself
and being for consciousness could possibly arise.
That is to say, where being in itself
is being for consciousness, and being for consciousness
is being for being in itself.
Now, there's various names for that that Hegel has.
One is, where truth becomes identical to certainty.
One of the names for the in itself is truth.
Another name for it is, another name
for being for consciousness is certainty.
So where truth and certainty are so closely identified
that none of the skeptical problems
that undermine forms of consciousness
could possibly arise.
The official name for this is absolute knowing.
That's where the book ends.
OK.
So the book ends with section absolute knowing,
or absolute knowledge, absolute citizen.
I've put it on the reading next week,
because although the idea of this class
is let's read all the parts of Hegel you can read,
I want you to also have a sense of what I'm sparing you.
So try to read absolute knowing.
You won't really succeed.
It's kind of unreadable.
Just a word further about reading in this class,
if I were you, I would expect to read every text,
every one of the readings in this class, three times.
Read it once, and you'll be like, what is going on?
I sort of a vague sense.
Read it a second time, you'll understand much better.
So the good news with Hegel is you do actually understand it
the more you read it.
Sometimes it won't feel that way.
Now the phenomenology of getting really into Hegel,
phenomenology in the ordinary sense of what it feels like,
is you're constantly understanding it better.
So you're tempted into the fallacy.
Eventually, I'll understand it all.
But constant improvement doesn't mean
that you'll ever reach any finite value,
because it might plateau.
This is my worry.
This is what keeps me up.
This is time.
This is staying to understanding.
And then actual understanding would be here.
But who knows?
But I'm constantly increasing every time I'm going up,
ever less.
So let me just say a few more things.
I forgot to say something about course mechanics.
My office hours this week are.
Wednesday 4.30 to 6, and Friday 3 to 4.
My office hours will vary from week to week,
because there's all these different job searches going
on in the philosophy department.
And I have to attend some of them.
Some of you have asked me about secondary literature.
My attitude towards secondary literature
is the attitude towards those of you who have cool Gen X
parents probably have towards your doing drugs, which
is they tell you, do not do them.
But if you were to do drugs, your parents
would give you advice on how to do them safely.
They would tell you, OK, don't do heroin.
But if you could smoke a little weed,
we're not going to throw you out of the house.
So my advice is do not do drugs.
Do not read secondary literature.
But if you're going to, I would prefer
you do it in a controlled, safe environment.
And you do the marijuana equivalent of Hegel
secondary literature rather than the fentanyl equivalent.
I won't even tell you what the fentanyl equivalent of Hegel
secondary literature is, because I don't
want you to know about it.
So if you come to me and you say,
stay, I am going to read secondary literature.
I'll try to talk you out of it.
But if I fail to, I'll give you some advice on what to read.
So another analogy.
Reading the secondary literature,
it's the older version of using AI.
So why is it bad to use AI?
Do you learn nothing?
Are all the answers on Claude or Chachupiti wrong?
No, you can learn stuff from that.
But if you use AI, you do not develop your own capacities
till now.
And that is what an education is about.
An education is not about us telling you stuff
that you didn't know.
You could do that on your own.
An education is about developing your own capacities.
And when you use AI, you do not develop your own capacities.
The aim of learning is not that it be known the P.
It is for me to know the P. So when
you read secondary literature, what you do not develop
is your own capacity to read and engage
in philosophical text.
That was my little speech about why I hate AI
and why I hate secondary literature.
So another thing that I want to emphasize,
the phenomenology of spirit is a conceptual development.
So we talk about a process or a development
in phenomenology of spirit, a sequence
of shapes of consciousness.
This is not a historical or temporal sequence.
Although these shapes can be and are exhibited historically,
they correspond, to varying degrees,
to conceptions of knowing, conceptions
of the relation of the subject to the object that
have been present historically in different periods of history.
Now there's a distinction in the phenomenology,
which will come up numerous times
in this class between what is for consciousness
and what is for us.
I'm looking for a special chalk that I've already lost.
Under the whiteboard.
Is that not it?
No, it is not.
So I think I need the glasses to find the chalk.
This will be sorted out later.
So there's a distinction in the phenomenology
between what is for consciousness.
And what is for us.
Sometimes, Hegel uses the term in itself.
So that marks the distinction between what
a given shape of consciousness is aware of.
You're counted.
What is imminent to a given shape of consciousness?
What a given shape of consciousness
is aware of of itself?
What is for us is something that we
understand about that shape of consciousness,
but it doesn't understand about itself.
So we, as the readers of the phenomenology,
sometimes called the phenomenological observer,
will note certain things about shapes of consciousness.
That's not going to work.
That's kind of stupid.
Hegel never said that.
Or this sort of is like a previous shape of consciousness.
Or you can tell that this is going to be a problem.
Or consciousness will face this problem.
Those are not imminent remarks for consciousness.
So one other remark.
I talked about this a little bit last time,
and I felt like what I did so really unclearly.
Hegel uses, I'll just encompass the questions in a second.
Hegel is very typical of Hegel.
So there's this book called the Hegel dictionary.
If you were to read secondary literature,
which you should not do, you might be aware of it.
And the joke about the Hegel dictionary is every entry,
ultimately, if you read all the entries,
they ultimately just go back to idea or spirit.
Because everything is just another synonym
for idea or spirit.
So in Hegel, there's this problem of massive,
this multiplication of terms that all
refer to the same thing, but they mean different things.
Or there are different modes of presentation of one
underlying reality.
So consciousness, self-consciousness, reason,
and spirit in the phenomenology really all
refer to the same thing.
But they refer to that underlay.
They refer to spirit.
They refer to different grades or degrees
of that thing's conception of itself.
So that means they are all spirit in itself,
but they are not yet spirit for itself.
Spirit is in and for itself fully and totally
only at the end of the book.
Only at the end of the book are we
talking about a shape of consciousness
that is fully and completely aware of what it is.
But all along, they're in itself spirit.
So in itself sometimes means something like implicitly.
Well, for itself means explicitly.
Sorry, the exact opposite.
Now, that means when Hegel refers to something,
some shape of consciousness as reason,
he's referring to it at the highest level of actualization
that it is aware of itself.
So reason is spirit in itself that is not yet spirit.
Sorry, spirit in itself that is not yet spirit for itself.
It's only for itself reason.
Now, it's also for itself consciousness
and self-consciousness.
But Hegel doesn't call it that because, or doesn't usually
call it that because he wants to draw attention
that he's talking about this thing at a level where
it's aware of itself as reason.
These give rise.
And of course, between these is religion.
But I'm skipping that because some of you
at some point in this class are going
to have this lingering suspicion that this is just
all super poopy religious stuff.
And I'm trying to delay as long as possible
the anti-religious reaction to Hegel.
So I'm just going to skip the religion thing.
So when Hegel talks about reason,
he's talking about, in some sense, the same entity.
That's not the right word.
The same thing, also not the right word.
The same phenomenon as consciousness, self-consciousness,
and spirit, but at a lower level of its conception
of itself, of its understanding of itself as what it is.
So the process of the phenomenology of spirit
is consciousness coming to itself as spirit,
or spirit in itself becoming spirit in and for itself,
consciousness becoming fully and completely
aware of itself as spirit.
OK.
Questions about this.
Yes.
I'm still stumbling a little bit over the fact
that in the first distinction between what
is for consciousness and what is for us or in itself,
how in itself and for us can mean the same thing.
For me, they mean the opposite.
What is for me, I'm opposing what the object is for me.
I'm opposing to be different from what it is in itself.
Yes.
So OK.
So OK, good.
So what Hegel means by calling what's for us in itself
is that this is what consciousness is only
implicitly.
What it really is is something that isn't aware of.
Yeah.
So let me take a non-Hegelian example.
You might say the Renaissance doesn't realize
that what it is is the dissolution of Catholic era.
This is a full example.
But in itself, that's what it is.
It is this thing that's a better example.
Socrates, Hegel actually thinks, the appearance of Socrates
within Athenian society is the destruction
of Athenian society.
Once you have Socrates, the form of life
that is classical Athens can survive.
So Socrates is in himself the end
of the Athenian form of life.
But he's not that for himself.
That's why he's so surprised they want to put him to death.
He's not like, I'm bringing it all to an end, guys.
Because if he was, then they'd be like,
well, we have to kill you.
So there's a distinction between what
something is in itself implicitly,
but not yet if it's developed and realized for.
And what we as the observers can see on who knows what grounds,
it will eventually become and become
aware of itself explicitly as.
There was another one.
Yes.
Can we say consciousness and knowledge or experience?
No.
So experience, the technical meaning of experience in Hegel
is the process.
It's this.
It's one shape of consciousness undermining itself
and being replaced by an object.
That's what experience is.
So this, consciousness of an object,
is not technically what Hegel means by experience.
Yeah.
So just back to movie star twist, is that right?
So you said initially that knowing is often
a conflict with consciousness, perceive of the object.
Can you elaborate on that?
Because that's two kinds of a relation.
And if consciousness perceive of the object,
wouldn't that also be knowing?
Yeah, OK.
So first of all, I just want to note, no,
and this is relevant to the beginning of the book,
self-certainty, your sense of certainty.
So if this chalk is supposed to not get all over,
it means the pot is not succeeding.
It's because you wait for it.
It's probably because I wait.
It's probably my fault.
So knowing here is an incredible,
that's a very, very general term.
So we're not assuming at the beginning of the phenomenology
that knowing is anything like you would normally
assume in philosophy.
So it doesn't have a propositional object.
It isn't true justified belief.
It isn't opposed to illusion.
It isn't opposed to mere opinion or belief.
In sensuous certainty, just to anticipate,
knowing is just, sensuous certainty can't really
say this, but it's just sensuously
apprehending something.
This is knowing.
That's knowing.
Now that means that knowing in its most general sense
is just the being of an object for consciousness.
And so before we get, Hegel will develop
over the course of phenomenology notions of knowledge
that look more like what we normally
talk about in epistemology.
But at the very beginning, it's just
whether this can be an object of consciousness.
Yeah.
So for consciousness, consciousness
cannot see its own developments.
It's only from the standpoint of for us
that I can see the whole program.
At the beginning.
Yes.
Eventually, consciousness will become self-conscious
or aware of its development in the phenomenology.
We won't get there.
Yeah.
I want to clarify imminence, because, for example,
in your example, if Socrates himself is not aware of it
or himself, he's not aware of the fact
that he's a distraction of being in society,
then the fact that Socrates is such a distraction
would still be imminent, because it's not?
If you said it in the courtroom in which Socrates
is being tried, no.
But it would be imminent if you could,
as a Hegelian philosopher, figure out
the underlying structure of Athenian society
and then show that it cannot allow someone like Socrates
within it and that once you even have
the possibility of someone like Socrates,
it's no longer stable.
And that, therefore, historically destroys the Greek city
state and give rise eventually to the Roman form of life,
then you would have made explicit
and you would have done so purely imminently
within, so to speak, the logic of these different historically
determined shapes of life that Socrates
is the end of the Athenian society.
But that was merely an illustration.
I know, but in that case, it's not
imminent for Socrates, but it's imminent for the Athenian
society.
It can be developed imminently, even
if the people in that historical period are not aware of it.
Or in other ways, we're getting way ahead of ourselves.
History for Hegel is the process of contradictions
in themselves being contradictions for themselves.
That is to say, implicit contradictions becoming
explicit contradictions, people being like, oh, wait.
How can it be that all men are created equal in a doubt
by the creator of certain inalienable rights
if our entire society is founded on the labor of enslave?
There was a question over here.
Yes.
It's just a simple question.
So for that process, is Hegel actually
being prescriptive or descriptive?
Descriptive.
Yes.
Yeah, just a follow-up.
So knowing just become the object of consciousness,
how can it be at all with itself or contradict itself?
We'll see.
Yes.
Is there some even more meta thing
that's supposed to happen to the observer
as they move through the shapes of consciousness?
Yes.
I'm not going to emphasize that in this class,
but I'll talk about this a little bit.
But you, who I've never read the farm culture before,
are supposed to have your consciousness raised
to the level of spirit over the course of reading this book.
So that is to say, you are all spirit in itself,
but not yet spirit for itself, because you are not
aware of what you are, namely spirit and what spirit is.
So one of the roles the phenomenology of spirit
is supposed to play is to get you off to that level.
Now, the reason it's supposed to get you off to that level
is so that you can then begin Hegelian science.
So the phenomenology of spirit is essentially,
in a certain way, it's the prerequisite
for all of Hegel's classes at the University of Berlin.
And in fact, at the beginning of the encyclopedia,
he says something to the effect of like,
what if you want to take this class without a prerequisite?
And the answer is like, you can do that,
but there are certain objections you're not allowed to raise.
And this book answers all the objections
you're not allowed to raise when you take logic
at the University of Berlin in the 1820s with Professor
Hegel.
Now, I should have said this last time, but I didn't say it.
So the way you should think about this class
is the professor is Hegel.
But in classic German professor style,
he doesn't show up to his own lectures.
He sends his assistant, me, to teach his lectures
and to run his office out.
So what we're trying to do is figure out
what Professor Hegel thought, but he never shows up.
So all we have is his books and the guy
that he's forced to teach his classes for several years.
And also in classic German professor style,
we'll then completely ignore me and never help me professionally.
OK, that's why.
So let's start sense certainty.
Before I begin, who found this reading hard?
Who found this reading very hard?
OK, just to give you an idea of the phenomenology,
this is by far the easiest thing in the phenomenology.
This is the thing that everyone kind of
feels comfortable teaching in the phenomenology.
So let us begin with the very opening of sense certainty.
Now, in classic style, I have to sit down and read the text.
It seems somehow sacrilegious to stand while reading.
I don't feel the need to cover my head when reading Hegel,
but OK.
OK, so let me just dive in.
Knowing which is initially our object or immediately
can be nothing but immediate knowing of the immediate
or of what is.
Now, knowing is initially our object.
So we have to begin by talking about knowing.
We have to begin by talking about a shape of consciousness.
Now, this is the beginning.
That means we can't have arrived at this shape of consciousness
by something else.
So it can't have been mediated by a previous shape
of consciousness or anything else in knowing.
Now, mediation, this is a word you're
going to hear a million, million, million times in this class.
Just the simplest meaning of mediation,
I think just like the most general way
to think about it in Hegel, the place you should begin
is just mediation just means by means of something else
or by means of something else-ness.
But now notice, by means of something else
involves being one thing rather than another.
So mediation goes together with determinism.
So let me just give some examples.
Mediate knowing is knowing something
by knowing something else.
The classic example is inference.
If I know that Q, because I inferred it from P,
and if P then Q, then my knowledge of Q is immediate.
But that means if my knowledge is mediated,
there are other items of knowledge it is not.
It is determinantly Q rather than P or if P then Q.
For there to be immediate or inferential knowledge,
there has to be determinacy among the propositions.
Now, determinacy is being one thing rather than another.
Now, why does determinacy require mediation?
Because if I'm this rather than that, if I'm x rather than y,
I'm x partly by means of not being y.
So mediacy and determinacy go together.
Now, we have to start immediately.
Because this is the beginning, the beginning has to be immediate.
It can't be mediated by anything else.
But that means it also has to be indeterminate.
Now, what does it mean that we have to have an immediate knowing
which is initially our object, or immediately,
can be nothing but immediate knowing.
So we have to have an immediate conception of knowing,
not mediated by anything else.
If it were knowledge of something mediated,
then it wouldn't be an immediate conception of knowing.
Because in order for it to be knowledge of that mediated thing
or conceive of it, it would have to be knowledge of that thing
as opposed to something else.
And therefore, it would be mediated by that something else.
So we have to immediately start with immediate knowledge,
which is knowledge of the immediate.
Now, what is knowledge of the immediate?
It has to be knowledge of the indeterminate.
That is to say, we don't know this rather than that.
We just know this.
We don't know one object as opposed to another.
We just know the object.
Now, there's a theme in the sensuous certainty
that's going to be super important to this class
that I'm going to delay a little bit for the end of class.
And I'll just say it right now.
So Hegel assumes that what knowledge is
is knowledge of what is.
You know what is.
Just as you think about what is, you judge what is, et cetera.
So you can see this from the very first sentence
of the phenomenology.
It is natural supposition that in philosophy,
before one gets down to dealing with what is at issue,
namely, the actual cognition of what in truth is.
So basic assumption of phenomenology, what you know
is what is or what has been.
Now, you might ask, but don't I know things?
I can know shadows.
Not being is in a certain way a kind of being.
It's relevant or determinate with respect to being.
I want to set the being theme aside for now,
because I'll come back to it later,
and it's even more abstract than everything else.
So we start with an immediate form of knowledge.
That knowledge has to be immediate knowledge
or knowledge of the immediate.
Because otherwise, it would be mediated
by something else, some conception of its knowledge
as distinct from some other kind of knowledge,
and then it wouldn't be the beginning,
or knowledge of its object as distinct
from some other object, and it wouldn't be immediate.
So we know the first shape of consciousness
is immediate knowledge of the immediate.
It's just so it can't be knowing by mediation,
and it can't be knowledge of what is immediate.
Why?
Because knowledge determines what the object of knowledge is.
There has to be a fit between being for consciousness
and the object of consciousness.
So the being of consciousness, the being for consciousness
is immediacy, and the object is immediate.
We therefore are to alter nothing in the object
as it presents itself, and we must
keep our conceptualizing it apart
from our apprehending of it.
So that means both we as the phenomenological observer
simply have to observe what this immediate shape of knowing is.
It's not our job to alter it.
We have to just observe what this shape of consciousness
says about itself.
But likewise, this shape of consciousness
can't conceptualize its object.
Why?
Because conceptualizing something is determining it.
It's representing it as falling under one concept rather than
another, and that involves mediation.
Conceptualizing is mediate, so the immediate
has to be non-conceptual.
Let me just read a little bit from here.
The concrete content of sensuous certainty
permits itself to appear immediately
as the richest cognition.
So this shape of consciousness thinks of itself.
It's just immediate apprehension of the object.
It's sensuous because we're in consciousness,
and so we think the object is what determines what knowledge
is.
There's an object outside of consciousness
that is the thing that we have to map or match onto.
So it's sensuous, immediate circle.
And it thinks of itself as the richest form of cognition
because it lets the whole sensuous richness of the world
be what it is without bringing it under consciousness.
So Hegel is playing off this idea
that people had in this period that conceptualizing things
deprives them of their life or their richness.
Concepts, of course, are only about generalities.
I'll get to you in a second what things have in common.
And so when you conceptualize, you ignore the infinitely rich
particularity of every individual thing.
So this form of consciousness thinks,
I'm not doing any of that.
I'm not desiccating anything or generalizing.
I'm just purely apprehending everything immediately
in its sensuous richness.
Indeed, there's a knowing of an infinite wealth
in which no limit is to be found,
whether we venture out into the reaches of space and time
as the place where that wealth extends itself
or when we take a piece out of this pontitude
divided and thereby delve into it.
So there's no limits because a limit would,
if there were a limit,
there would be something beyond the limit
that would involve mediation.
So there's no limits extensively.
There's no point beyond sensuous certainty.
And there's no limits within the object.
Sensuous certainty can dive further into the object,
look further and further and further into the object.
In addition, it appears as the most veritable
where it has not omitted anything from its object
because it isn't conceptually determining it.
It's not leaving out some of its details
and conceptualizing only some of them.
But rather has its complete entirety before itself.
However, this certainty in fact yields the most abstract
and the very poorest truth.
It expresses what it knows as this.
It is.
And its truth only contains the being of the object.
Now this is, I wanna separate the being issue
from the it issue for the following reason.
It can't really properly speaking be the case
that what sensuous certainty knows is it is or this is
because that it is is not immediate
because it involves a subject and a predicate.
And so it would involve the difference
between a subject and a predicate.
It would involve immediate relationship
between subject and predicate.
It would be determining the it as being.
So I wanna focus on it and then I'll come back to it.
So now what Hegel is saying, he's gonna argue
that contrary to what sensuous certainty thinks,
it doesn't know, it isn't the richest
and most variegated form of consciousness.
In fact, what it does is the most universal and abstract.
So just a little bit further.
For sensuous certainty, this is what is essential
and this pure being where this simple immediacy
constitutes its truth.
So the truth is this, or it.
And being for consciousness certainty
is just immediate apprehending.
Likewise, as a relation certainty
is an immediate pure relation.
Consciousness is I, nothing further,
a pure this and the singular individual
knows a pure this or he knows the singular.
So let's just take the first shape of consciousness
to be I know this.
Where knowledge here is just immediate.
So I'm not conceptualizing this.
And so this is not an object of concepts.
It's not a thing with many properties.
All right, yes.
What is the root of immediate knowledge?
So immediate knowledge is knowledge
that isn't mediated by any other knowledge.
So the idea is to note, this is what sensuous certainty
thinks, to know this, I don't need to know anything else.
However, if what I knew about this was that it was a pencil,
I would need to know what a pencil is.
I would need to know the difference between pencil
and a pencil, that is to say the pencil
and the universal pencil, et cetera, et cetera.
But immediate knowledge is knowledge
not by means of anything else.
Wherever there's mediation, there's determinacy.
Being one thing and not being another.
So if there's no immediacy, there's no mediation,
there's no determinacy.
So I don't know this as opposed to something else.
I just know this.
So how do I know this if I see it for the first time?
That's what knowing is.
So you're assuming that to know this,
I need to know what it is.
I need to bring it under a concept.
Sensuous certainty is denying.
Sensuous certainty says, this is knowledge.
And so is this.
And so is this, yeah.
Isn't starting with immediate knowledge a kind of immediacy?
Because we're starting with immediacy
rather than mediacy.
Okay, great.
So that is gonna be the question.
So hold on to that question
until we get to the beginning of the science of logic.
Because I agree with you.
And I think that's the way we save
Pedagorean philosophy.
Yeah.
In the first like, I know or something,
it's like, it's as conceptualizing
and in the footnote is as conceptually comprehending.
Oh, yeah.
That's because Terry Pinkard loves to insert
his own interpretations into the translation.
Which is, so let me just, I'm actually not seeing,
where is the footnote actually?
It's on the first page and.
Yeah, but what sentence does it modify?
I have so many.
It's the last sentence of 90.
The last sentence.
Oh, conceptualizing.
Yeah, so let's see what that is.
That's almost certainly gonna be Begrifen.
And Terry loves to translate Begrifen
as conceptually comprehending, which is hilarious.
Yeah, it's Begrifen.
Okay, Begrifen just means comprehending or conceptualizing.
It doesn't mean both.
That is to say, basic rule of translation.
Where there's one word, don't translate it as two words.
Okay, like that just doesn't work.
Okay, so what that should really be is comprehending.
Okay, now the reason he's translated
as conceptually comprehending,
this is in German, Begrifen,
is the word in German for concept is Begrif.
That's what a concept is.
Which is the noun form of the verb Begrifen,
which is also to grasp.
So Begrifen is also a grasping.
So in some ways, obviously it's a conceptualizing.
But in general, the closest thing in English to Begrifen
in philosophical texts is comprehending,
comprehending something.
So you should just translate it as comprehending.
Or you could translate it as conceptualizing,
but you do not wanna translate it
as conceptually comprehending.
That's just adding complexity that's not in the original.
Okay, so what Hegel is saying is
we must not conceptualize this thing.
Any, our job is to just ask what sensuous certainty says
about itself, not to bring our own concepts to bear
on and make sensuous certainty
into something that we think it should be.
Okay, so now going further,
we're gonna skip 92, the end of 93.
The I, a knowing that knows the object only
for the reason that the object is,
but which itself can just as well be as not be.
So that means, so just to anticipate,
sensuous certainty is gonna undergo various changes
over the course of this chapter.
So Hegel begins by talking about
just the bare abstract idea,
or I'm sorry, just you start someone
by talking sensuous certainty,
and then imminently criticizes it.
And then sensuous, he allows sensuous certainty
to modify itself in light of those imminent criticisms
while remaining sensuous certainty.
So the first form of sensuous certainty
is one on which, in Hegelian terms,
the object, this, is the essence.
That means the object determines what it is to know it,
which means the object can be there
whether or not the subject is,
or the subject is purely receptive in knowing the object.
So the I, a knowing that knows the object
only for the reason that the object is,
but which itself can just as well be as not be.
So the knowing can be or not be, and the object still is.
However the object is, it is the true and the essence.
The object is indifferent as to whether it's known or not.
The object remains even when it is not known,
but if the object does not exist, then there is no known.
The object is therefore to be considered
in terms of whether, in sensuous certainty itself,
it is in fact the kind of essence
which sensuous certainty passes it off as being.
That is to say, is immediate,
is immediate knowing a way of knowing this?
That's the question,
because that's what sensuous certainty says it is.
That is, it is to be considered as to whether this,
its concept, its conception of itself,
the object and the being of the object forehead,
which is to be the essence,
corresponds to the way it is present within that certainty.
To that end, we need not reflect on the object
and mull over what it might be in truth.
We need only to consider it as sensuous certainty
has it in sensuous certainty itself.
That is to say, we just have to do this imminently
rather than transcendently, non-imminently,
applying our own criteria to value.
Therefore, sensuous certainty itself is to be asked,
what is this?
If we take it in the twofold shape of its being
as the now and the here,
so one interesting thing about the phenomenology
is Hegel assumes from page one
that consciousness is consciousness
of objects in space and time.
So whatever the project of the phenomenology is,
he's not trying to answer the skeptic who's like,
I didn't say anything about space and time.
And as we'll see, he even assumes some very natural things
about the structure of space and time,
namely that it's divisible.
So whatever the phenomenology is supposed to do,
it's not supposed to refute the skeptic
who denies that objects outside the mind
are in space and time,
nor is it supposed to derive space and time
from something more fundamental,
which weirdly is part of the project of the Hegel system.
Notoriously.
So what I know can be characterized just purely imminently.
We're just unfolding what's sent to a certainty.
What I know is this here now,
if we take it in the twofold shape of its being
as the now and here,
then the dialectic,
where the, remember the dialectic
is the internal imminent dialectic
of a Hegel consciousness,
where it generates contradictions of itself
and tries to resolve them.
The dialectic, which it has in itself,
will take on a form as intelligible as the this itself.
To the question, what is the now?
We answer, for example, the now is the night.
So if we ask sensuous conscious,
so this is a slightly artificial example
that Hegel uses to make a point.
So I'll just read it and then I'll explain
what the point is.
We answer, for example, the now is night.
In order to put the truth of this sensuous certainty
to the test, a simple experiment will suffice.
We write down this truth.
A truth cannot be lost by being written down anymore
than it can be lost by our preserving it.
And if now, this midday, we look at this truth,
which has been written down,
we will have to say that it has become rather staged.
Okay, so the idea is the sentence,
now is night.
Is true, say, at 11 p.m. and is false at 2 p.m.
So what Hegel is doing is arguing that
in so far as sensuous certainty
says that knowledge is I know this here now,
it cannot make sense of now.
Why?
Because Hegel argues in the next paragraph
that now is a universal.
That is to say, it applies to multiple different times.
It applies to every time at the time at which it's uttered.
So for any time, now uttered at that time
refers to that time.
Now refers to noon, 1 p.m. and 2 p.m.
Okay, now why would it be bad
if the object of knowledge for sensuous certainty
were a universal?
It would be bad because a universal is a one over a minute.
It applies to multiple particulars.
But that means it is distinct from the particulars
it applies to, and they are distinct from one another,
which means that to know a universal requires determinancy.
This is determinately this rather than that,
and determinately a particular rather than a universal,
and a universal is a determinately a universal
rather than a particular.
That means knowledge of a universal requires mediation.
You know what a universal is
by means of knowing it isn't a particular,
namely the things that it can instantiate.
But there can't be anything immediate
in the object of sensuous certainty,
so this cannot characterize its object.
Now in contemporary philosophy,
it's very weird to think of now as a universal.
If you said that in contemporary philosophy of language,
class, Imogen Dickey would kill you.
So the more natural thing is to think of it now
as what we call an indexical.
Which is to say, something that refers to different things
under different contexts of utterances, contexts of utterance.
So now, as uttered at time t,
refers to time t.
So that's the more contemporary way
of expressing the nature of now.
That it's an indexical rather than a universal.
But Hegel's point remains,
because this also requires the difference
between individual times
and a general quantifier over times.
This says for all times,
so in order for sensuous certainty
to have an indexical expression
in the objects of its knowledge,
it would have to understand indexicals.
Which involves understanding that one expression
can refer to different things at different times.
That requires determinacy, requires mediation.
So the same argument eliminates the indexical now
from being within the content
of sensuous certainty's knowledge.
The same arises for Hugh,
as Hegel goes on to say.
We also express the sensuous, this is 98.
The same case comes up in the other form of the this,
namely in the here.
For example, here is the tree.
I turn around this truth vanishes,
and it has inverted itself into its contrary.
Here there is not a tree, but rather a house.
The here itself does not disappear,
rather it endures in the disappearance of the house,
the tree, and it is indifferent to being a house, a tree.
But this shows itself again to be a mediated simplicity
or as being universality.
So once again, Hegel thinks of here as a universal.
That's slightly odd in a contemporary perspective
to think that here is a universal
that's instantiated by every location.
It's more natural to think of it
as a indexical for all locations L.
As utter at L refers to L.
If you want me to write out the clause for this.
So the problem with this, right,
is it depends on where you're pointing.
And a disgraced former colleague of mine,
Colin McGinn, has this famous paper
where he tries to settle the question
exactly which object is referred to by pointing.
And so he literally has in this paper a diagram of a hand.
And then there's this question of like,
well, it's obviously, it doesn't have to be exactly.
So like, you know, there's like a cone of reference
and there's like an empirical question,
what is the angle theta?
Like if I say, can I say this
and be referring to the lectern?
No, it's too far away.
There, can I be referring to the lectern?
Questionable, definitely.
So somewhere there's this vague boundary
of the theta of reference.
This is what, okay, this is what people
like Colin McGinn spend their time doing.
Okay.
The fact that it was a hand is deeply ironic.
So even if we think of here as an indexical
expression rather than a universal,
the same point applies.
Because this requires there being a distinction
between the general term location
and the individual locations.
That is to say, since you're certain
you would have to understand differences among locations
and the difference between a location
and the general term location.
That requires, that is determinate
and that means it's median.
You understand one thing via an object.
And it can't do that.
So it also can't have here in the content of what it knows.
Yes.
Doesn't the,
Colin, thinking of knowledge as a knowledgeable object
already presumed like a distinction between objects
rather than just being an object,
which to say now is night I feel
it's already kind of giving some certainty,
something that's uncertainty has already denounced.
Now is not, it just is, isn't it?
Exactly.
And that means that either,
so what you're really showing is
sense certainty shouldn't even be talking
about here and now.
It should just say, I know this.
Or if it wants to say here and now,
it should just refuse to look at any other objects
or at any other time.
That is to say, it should say,
what I know is this here now,
don't tell me about any other objects or at any other times.
I'm saying it shouldn't even recognize other objects.
It just exists.
Exactly.
So Hegel's going to modify sensuous certainty
to answer his own objection in the direction
that you're indicating.
Okay.
Yeah.
So this situation of I determines universal of no.
So now in time, so now as P1 or P2 or P3
is dependent on my situation.
Yeah, so Hegel's going to do exactly the same move
with I in one second.
Because I is also an index.
That is to say, in his terms, it's a universal.
We would think of it more naturally as an index.
But before we got there,
Hegel said something really important in 97.
We also express the sensuous as a universal,
but we say is this,
i.e. the universal this,
or we say it is, i.e. being as such.
Let's leave the being theme aside.
We thereby, of course, do not represent to ourselves
the universal, this for being as such,
but we express the universal.
Or in this sensuous certainty,
we do not at all say what we mean.
So there's a distinction,
this is totally central to sensuous certainty
between what we say and what we mean,
by which Hegel means what we intend to say.
So he's going to argue that what sensuous certainty
intends to mean is this particular piece of chalk.
But what it actually says is the universal this.
So it can't say what it means to say.
So what sensuous certainty is trying to do is express
that what it knows is particulars.
But with only this here and now, it can't do that.
Because Hegel will argue over the course of the chapter,
to know a particular, you have to have both
something like this here and now,
call it an indexical, call it an intuition,
and a conception of a universal.
You have to distinguish this from other particulars
in terms of its properties.
So sensuous certainty thinks of itself
that it knows individual particulars.
But what it says is, I know this,
and this is a universal.
Because that's this, that's this, that's this.
Everything's at this.
So if what it knows is this, it knows,
rather than this.
Yeah.
I'm confused because I thought we are not,
we're trying to not conceptualize in answering
for the sensuous certainty person.
But then we introduce the concept of a universal.
Wouldn't they just not conceptualize that?
Right.
So one background worry here is whether Hegel is
making sensuous certainty answer questions
that according to sensuous certainty's own concept
of itself, it doesn't have to.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's important to note that sensuous certainty
is not just mute.
It's not like, this is not caveman consciousness.
So it has a conception of itself of what it knows.
Now, it can conceptualize its knowledge
without thinking that what it knows
is a conceptualized object.
So in order, the whole setup is that we're examining
concepts of knowledge.
So sensuous certainty has to have a concept of itself.
But what it knows is the object,
and it knows it non-conceptually.
Which means the project of the phenomenology
is not to take each conception of knowledge and then ask,
does that, or each shape of consciousness
that has a conception of knowledge,
ask does that shape of consciousness
know its conception of knowledge?
That is to say, we don't take the concept of knowledge
and put it on the object side.
Because sensuous certainty would immediately fail that.
Because a concept of knowledge is conceptual.
So sensuous certainty doesn't think it knows
its concept of knowledge.
That's just what it says if you ask it.
What I know is this.
But your concept of knowledge is not a this,
yeah, yeah, yeah, epistemology is kind of bullshit.
It's not something that it knows.
It's just how it answers.
It's how it conceives of this.
And so it would be cheating, it would be cheap
if we were like, well, you don't know that.
It's supposed to be not cheating if what we say is,
that immediate knowledge isn't knowledge of that object.
It's not the object that you intend to know,
the object that you mean.
The object that you say is something different.
Yeah?
Well, why not start with the caveman consciousness?
Well, because it's really hard to argue with caveman, right?
The epistemological version of,
oh, I'm just a caveman lawyer, right?
I, that was just a gesture and a joke.
I didn't really know what I needed to tell you that through.
Yeah, because caveman consciousness
sort of,
by definition, doesn't have the conception of itself as knowledge.
Okay, and that might mean, so background question,
is Hegel assuming something to the effect that if you know,
maybe you don't know you know,
but you can coherently conceptualize your knowledge
in a way that survives imminent dialectical critique?
I think he is, potentially.
Okay, so we've talked about 97 and 98, time check.
Let's take a 10 minute break.
Consciousness, Hegel has raised these problems
for sensuous certainty.
Here and now are universals.
Therefore, either what sensuous certainty knows
is the universal this,
which applies to absolutely everything.
Or, insofar as it wants to know this,
it can't use here or now to figure it out.
Okay, now sensuous certainty modifies itself.
And it modifies itself in the direction
of making itself the essence.
Now what that means is, it says,
okay, I determine what this is,
because what is here or what is now,
or what is this, is what is,
it is where I am, and when I am, and what I'm pointing to.
So it tries to solve this problem of this here now
by anchoring the reference of this here and now to the I.
So I could write those out, those indexical expressions,
indexical clauses, using I, but I won't bother,
because we can all see what the problem is gonna be.
The problem is going to be that I itself is an indexical.
I, as uttered by any subject S, refers to S.
So Hegel will say I is a universal.
I refers indifferently to every subject that can say I.
Or, if we take the more contemporary conception
on which it's an indexical,
that cannot be within the content of what consciousness knows.
Consciousness is explanation of how it knows its object
cannot go by universals.
So now Hegel says that this is the bottom of 102,
oh he's saying 101, this just expresses this idea
of tying, of using the I to anchor
the reference of here and now.
Now is daytime, because I see it.
Here is a tree for precisely the same reason,
however sensuous certainty experiences
in these relationships, the same dialectic
as it did within the preceding relationships.
I, this, see the tree and assert the tree to be tree,
to be here.
Now, properly speaking, it doesn't assert anything
to be here, that's 8%.
However, another I sees the house
and asserts that there is no tree here, but rather a house.
Both truths have the same warrants,
namely the immediacy of seeing and the surety
and the seerons, which both have about their knowing,
however one vanishes into the other.
So I see a house, Christa sees a tree,
I see a house, I see a tree.
They can't both be right.
And sensuous certainty, or let's see, I see a tree,
I see a non-tree, or I don't see a tree.
They can't both be right,
and sensuous certainty doesn't have the means
to distinguish the two in the way we would by saying,
when I say I see a tree, it means Nick Stang sees a tree.
And when Christa says I see a non-tree,
it means Christa sees a tree,
because that would involve having the distinction
between the universal, one who can say I,
and particular people who can say I.
Okay, 102, the beginning of 102,
I've already explained what's going on.
So then at the very bottom of page 63,
however much this demand is set before science
as its touchstone,
a demand which it would surely not last out,
namely the deduce, construct, find a priori,
however one wishes to express it,
a so-called this thing, or this person,
still it is reasonable that the demand should state
which of the many things this thing,
or which of the eyes this I means,
but it is impossible to state this.
So sensuous certainty says,
what it knows is this here now,
but it cannot, compatible with its own shape or consciousness,
say which thing it knows.
And so either it knows the universal,
which is what it says, but it doesn't want to say that,
it doesn't mean to say that,
or it needs to be modified.
Okay, 103, sensuous certainty therefore learns
from experience in the technical Hegelian sense
that its essence is neither in the object nor in the eye,
and in the immediacy is in immediacy
of neither one or the other of them.
For in both, what I mean is instead what is inessential,
and the object and eye are universals
in which the now and the human eye
that me and do not endure are not.
So it's tried making the object be essential,
a thing that determines what knowing is,
it's tried making itself the essential
by using it to anchor the reference of here and now,
neither worked.
We thereby come to posit the whole of sensuous certainty
itself as its essence,
and no longer only as a moment of sensuous certainty
as happened in both cases,
in which at first the object approaches the eye,
and the eye itself reaches supposed to be
the reality of sensuous certainty.
It is thus only the whole of sensuous certainty itself,
which links tenaciously in such sensuous certainty
to immediacy, in which thereby excludes from itself
all the opposition that took place in what proceeding.
So sensuous certainty realizes,
okay, I tried making the object the essence,
I tried making myself the essence, neither worked.
So you need to think of it,
they're both essential or neither.
I'm not gonna talk about essence anymore.
So I'm just gonna take sensuous certainty itself.
This situation of I know this,
that's gonna be the whole thing.
This pure immediacy therefore no longer has any concern
with the otherness of the here as a tree,
which is a here that is a non-tree,
nor with the otherness of now as daytime,
and which passes over into a now that is night,
nor with another eye,
for which something other is the object.
So this new shape of self-consciousness,
new shape of self-censored certainty claims,
look, I know this, and if you raise any objections
about trees or houses, things I don't know now,
that isn't this, I'm going to ignore you.
Or you could think of this as episodic sensuous certainty.
This sensuous certainty knows this, now it knows this.
And if you ask it, but now is the water bottle,
now is the pencil is no longer true,
what are you talking about?
So now it's immunized itself
against all of these Hegelian objections.
So really these earlier Hegelian objections
were just moves to get you to see the logic of the game.
Because this is where sensuous certainty
should have started from.
Because all of these problems that were brought in
were really properly speaking things
that sensuous certainty never claimed to them.
Objects that weren't sensuously present to them,
like the tree when it was only perceiving the house,
weren't only sensing the house.
Like the daytime when now is night.
And other eyes.
So now sensuous certainty doesn't want to hear anything
about a house when it's looking at a tree.
It doesn't want to hear anything about daytime
when it's night.
And it doesn't want to hear anything about eyes.
And if you raise that, it's going to tell you,
I don't know what you're talking about.
None of that's knowledge, that's all bullshit.
Don't.
I just have one question.
Is it maybe even when we're talking about something
like this thing, you could call it an object?
Or is it more just like a bundle of sense data or something?
Bundle of sense data already brings in too much.
And object is a super, super general notion.
It's literally just the accusative.
That is to say, it's what consciousness is of.
Whenever there's of-ness, there's an object.
However much you use the word object, but OK.
So at this stage, we're at the real caveman consciousness?
Except that, unlike the caveman,
it has a conception of its known.
Otherwise, the whole project wouldn't go on.
You cannot argue with cavemen.
I mean, probably you could argue with cavemen.
There's a great book about how it's called
The Dawn of Everything by Ray Rundland Groud.
And the basic idea is we all think
of a prehistoric, so-called hunter-gatherer,
societies as really boring and life-having soft.
But actually, it was probably way better.
It's just talking about consciousness
or the sense of certain telling us something.
I just wonder, because in this book,
there's a concept called cognitive impenetrability.
It says that in perception, it just perception itself.
It doesn't tell us anything.
But some people also argue that we can actually
perceive some high-order property in things,
for example, like unity, identity, and so on.
Yeah, so this conception, this model of consciousness
is several levels more primitive than anything
you would find in contemporary analytic philosophy
or cognitive science.
Because this has not been developed
because it's plausible as an account of consciousness
or because it's something that emerges naturally
from the sciences.
It's been introduced purely to get the project started.
This is way more primitive than any conception
of perceptual consciousness that you will find
in contemporary literature.
Let's just read a little bit further.
This pure immediacy, therefore, no longer has any concern
with the otherness of the here as a tree,
which is a here that is a non-tree,
nor the otherness of now is daytime,
which passes over into a now that is night,
nor with another eye, for which something other is the object.
Its truth is preserved as a self-consistent relation,
which makes no difference of essentiality
and non-essentiality between the eye and the object,
and into which, therefore, no difference at all
can force its entry.
I, this eye, assert therefore that here is a tree.
Once again, shouldn't say is a tree, just here.
Happens to be a tree.
And it's not the case that I turn around
so that the here would become for me not a tree,
or that I myself, at another time,
take the here not to be a tree,
the now not to be the daytime.
Rather, I am pure intuitive,
and I stick with, namely, that now is daytime,
or else I also stick with here is a tree.
I also do not compare the here and the now themselves
with each other.
Rather, I cling tenaciously to an immediate relation.
Now it is daytime.
So any of these previous or past experiences,
any other objects in the environment,
any other subjects are now just being completely left out
by sensuous certainty as objects of knowledge.
Since the certainty itself no longer wishes to step forward
when we draw its attention to a now that is night,
or to an eye for which it is night,
we step up to it and let ourselves point
to the now that is a certainty.
So this angles, the metaphor is supposed to be,
we now take up the standpoint of sensuous certainty.
We look out from the eyes of sensuous certainty.
Thus we must enter into the same point of time or space,
point it out to ourselves,
allow ourselves to be made into the same eye
as that is a knowing uncertainty.
Let us see therefore how what is immediate,
which is pointed out to us is composed.
Okay, so now Hegel first makes the point
that he's going to make in 106 and 107 about time.
And because it's about time,
it's a little bit more complicated.
But I'll just say it about time,
you'll get the basic structure of it,
and then we'll talk about space.
So he first makes it about now, then he makes it about here.
So the point about now is that I say,
what I know is this here now,
saying that takes a certain amount of time.
And I haven't said it until I've said all of it.
But by the time I've said it,
what I intended to say,
the object that I intended to say that I know
the beginning of that no longer is.
Because if it did, if the object persisted,
it would be a universal.
It would be a thing that's one over many.
Not a property, but a thing that can exist
at different times.
And so for consciousness,
to be able to give an account of why this here now
refers either to the first moment of the thing,
or the whole life of the thing,
it would be able to have to distinguish
the thing as a universal,
or a thing that endures through time
from its various moments of time.
And that requires mediation.
That requires a distinction among things.
And that is not something that such a certain can know.
So the idea is,
time is not,
there's more than one moment of time.
So Hegel's just assuming there's more than one moment of time.
Thinking the thought, what I know is this here now,
or what I know is this now, takes some time.
You haven't finished it until all that time has passed.
But the object, the moment of time that began,
no longer is, so either you're no longer able
to refer to that moment of time,
or you're referring to a thing that persists through time,
and that requires mediation.
That requires the idea of a thing
that exists at different times.
Is Hegel also assuming time is infinitely divisible?
I don't think he's assuming it's infinitely divisible.
I think he's assuming it's divisible.
But he might be assuming it's infinitely divisible.
The most he's assuming is that it's orbital.
He's infinitely divisible.
He's not assuming it's infinitely divided.
That is to say, there's always a smaller interval of time.
So that's the time point.
More complicated.
The here point is much simpler.
So 108.
The here that has been pointed out
and to which I cling is likewise a this here,
which is in fact not this here,
but is rather an in front of and behind
or an above and below or a right and left.
So I refer to something that is spatially complex.
That is to say, has parts.
The here, which is supposed to be pointed out,
vanishes into another here, but that one likewise vanishes.
That is to say, here could refer,
if I say here, that could refer to the whole object
or refer to any of its parts.
What is pointed out, held onto and which endures
is a negative this, which only is as the here's are taken
as they're supposed to be, but which in being so taken
have sublated themselves.
It is a simple summary of many years.
Why did you guys do this to yourself?
You could have taken bioethics instead you're reading this.
Okay, so what he means by that is
so he's assuming that physical objects
are spatially extended, so they have parts.
The thing that sensuous surgery knows
is a spatially complex object with parts.
And that means that it's spatially universal.
That is to say, it's in all of these parts.
Which means that to be conscious of it
as opposed to any of its parts requires mediation.
So why would I say this here, this here now,
am I referring to the whole book rather than its parts?
The only thing that could explain why my consciousness
is of this whole book rather than its parts
is because I'm aware of it as a book with parts
rather than as the parts.
I have to consciously separate it from its background,
from its environment, and from its parts
to be conscious of it as the whole object it is.
The same problem applies if I want to be conscious
of the page as opposed to the whole book,
I have to be conscious of the page rather than the book.
And that requires negation and that's a form of determinacy
which is a form of mediation.
And that is not allowed by essentially certainty.
The here that is meant would be the point.
However, the point is not, but rather as the point
is demonstrated as existing, the demonstrating points
to itself as showing itself to be not immediate knowing
but instead of movement from out of the many years
which we meant into the universal here,
which is a simple plurality of years
in the way that the daytime is a simple plurality of that.
What does that mean?
What that means is Hegel admits the existence
of spatial points, but they have their being
in being the intersection of lines,
which have their being in being the intersection of planes,
which have their being in being the intersection of solids.
That is to say, to be conscious of a point
is mediated by consciousness of the line
that intersects at that point.
So consciousness of a point is totally okay,
but it's immediate.
Okay, now what is Hegel assuming
about the composition of space here?
He's assuming that it is infinitely divisible
because if there were,
he seems to be assuming that it's infinitely divisible.
I'd have to think about whether this argument
could work without that assumption,
but he does seem to be assuming that.
Okay.
Okay, so the idea is sensuous certainty says,
okay, look, forget all these other objects.
All I know is this here now,
but now why is its consciousness of the whole pencil
rather than the tip of the pencil,
the upper half of the pencil,
the lower half of the pencil,
the color of the pencil, et cetera?
The only thing that it could do that
is because it's conscious of this thing
as a unity of parts,
which means it has to have a conception of the whole
as opposed to the parts.
That's just to say,
it has to have mediacy within the content of its consciousness.
Okay, so now to go back to this,
so one of the classic worries
about Hegel's critique of sensuous certainty
is that he's putting in sensuous certainty
the amount of things that sensuous certainty
doesn't have to say.
This is Zopan's question about,
it's caveman consciousness.
Now, if sensuous certainty was literally just mute,
like staring at things,
without any conception of itself as knowing,
obviously Hegel's critique would not be imminent,
but that just means that that can't possibly
be the project of the world.
So a shape of consciousness is a shape of consciousness.
That is to say,
it's something that has a conception of itself
as relating to an object.
That means it has to have a conception
of why its consciousness is a consciousness of its object.
And Hegel is assuming that the consciousness
of the sensuous certainty's consciousness of its object,
if that consciousness is not conceptually mediated,
can't be a consciousness of a whole thing apart.
Can you just explain what exactly the sensuous certainty
person can afford to distinguish without concepts?
Is it between particulars,
or is it between the concept of a universal
and that of a particular?
So what it can say,
so we're allowing it to say things in answer to us,
which involves concepts,
but what it can know involves no concepts.
In sorry, it involves no universals.
All it knows is this here now.
So he tries to avoid Hegel's critique
by claiming that this here now is not a universal
because it doesn't care about the other instances,
it just cares about this.
But Hegel's point is that even this,
being conscious of this,
requires consciousness of a universal.
It requires a consciousness of a one over man.
And that means it requires consciousness
of the one as being distinct from them,
which is determinism, and that's a kind of mediation.
Now, let's go a little bit further.
109, it is clear both that the dialectic
of sensuous certainty is nothing but the simple history
of its movement that is its experience.
So the dialectic of sensuous certainty
is just this sequence of experiences,
which is to say its awareness of apparent contradictions
between its consciousness of the object and the object
and attempts to resolve them.
And that sensuous certainty itself is nothing
but just this history.
So the shape of consciousness,
Hegel's now identifying with its own experience.
Or sensuous certainty is,
this is not something happening to sensuous certainty
on that side, we're not doing anything to sensuous certainty.
Sensuous certainty, just purely the concept
of sensuous certainty when thought thread
generates these problems.
For that reason, natural consciousness also proceeds
to this result, what is the true in sensuous certainty
to keep pressing the other forward.
It learns from experience about it,
but then it likewise forgets it,
and then it starts the whole movement all over again
right from the beginning.
It is thus a bit astonishing
when in the face of this experience,
it is set up as a philosophical assertion,
whereas a universal experience,
or even as the outcome of skepticism,
that the reality or the being of external things as this
or as sensuous is to have absolute truth for consciousness.
Such an assertion does not say at,
does not say at the same, does not at the same time
know what it is saying.
It does not know what it is saying,
the opposite of what it wants to say.
So sensuous certainty wants to say
that the object of consciousness is the pencil
in saying, all I know is this.
But actually, this is a universal.
In fact, this is the most abstract universal,
because everything is a this.
So now, let me turn to the theme
that I said I would talk about, which is being.
So sensuous certainty's official view is I know this.
Now Hegel sometimes says what it knows is,
I know this is, but that makes the object of consciousness
complex, that is to say there's a difference
between the subject and the predicate.
You can't have that.
So we're properly speaking, what it knows is this.
But we can also just characterize that object as it.
What it knows is it, or being.
Now the object of consciousness has to be completely immediate.
Immediacy goes with indeterminacy.
Why?
Because immediacy is the same or goes with determinacy.
If something is determinate, it's
one thing rather than another, it
is what it is in virtue of what it is not.
So if something has a determinate color, it's red.
It's red in virtue of not being blue.
Likewise, if something is mediated,
it has to be mediated by something else.
So it has to be determinately, not that.
Now, there is this thing called self-mediation in Hegel.
Something can mediate itself.
But then there's a difference, there's
determinacy between the role of the thing as mediator
and the very same thing as mediator.
So wherever there's mediation, there's
determinacy, wherever there's determinacy, there's mediator.
So wherever there's lack of mediacy,
wherever there's immediacy, there's indeterminacy.
So what if I know is this and it's immediate,
it's an indeterminate this.
Now, this is all stuff that we are saying.
This is not something that consciousness gets at.
This is for us, not for some sensuous certainty.
What I know is the indeterminate this.
So what sensuous certainty is saying
is I know this, which is not just the cosmos.
Because the cosmos is a determinate this.
It's the most indeterminate possible this.
Another way of putting that is what consciousness knows
is not this determinate being, but completely indeterminate
being.
What it knows is being, pure being.
OK.
That means there's a structural parallel,
this is just to anticipate a couple of things,
between sensuous certainty and the beginning
of the science of logic.
The beginning of the first category of the science
of logic is pure being.
OK.
Now, question.
I myself am not really sure what I want to say about this.
So Hegel draws a distinction between what sensuous certainty
says and what it means.
What it says it knows is pure being,
completely indeterminate being.
You take away all immediacy, you take all way determinacy.
It's not that I know this being, because this being is
this being, a virtue of not being, some other being.
It's a determinate being, or a specific being,
mediated by some other being.
So completely immediate being, which
is the absolutely pure, general being.
Not just not even God, because God is traditionally
conceived of as a being, a very special being,
but one being among others, just pure being.
So what Hegel says is sensuous certainty
says what it knows is pure being.
But what it means is it knows this being, this particular
being.
And so this contrast, this conflict,
shows that this form of consciousness is incoherent.
But you could argue on behalf of sensuous certainty.
No.
What you've shown is that sensuous certainty
knows pure being.
Now, I'm not sure what to do with that.
And I want to leave this open, because one
of the big problems in the science of logic
is why, what entitles us to go beyond pure being?
So why can't sensuous, why isn't Hegel just proven
that what knowing is is the knowing of pure being?
Done.
Book ends.
Now, one thing that Hegel could say is, look,
it might be that knowing is just the pure knowing
of pure being.
But that's not sensuous.
Whatever your access to pure being is,
it's not through the senses.
So that definitely is not what sensuous certainty means to me.
It may be what it says, but it doesn't mean to me.
So I just want to flag that.
So this distinction between what sensuous certainty says
and what it means.
So first of all, general irony of the phenomenology.
What is for consciousness is not always
the same as what is for us.
So certain things will seem a certain way to consciousness,
but the observer can see that it's not that way.
Irony is when the apparent meaning
is different from the actual meaning.
So Oedipus is like, why is there this plague affecting Athens?
Someone must have cured it in some terrible crime.
I wonder who it is.
And we're like, we all know why.
So likewise, there's an irony here
in that sensuous certainty thinks
that what it knows is the super concrete sensuous particulars.
What it really knows is the most abstract thing of all, pure being.
Now, the other thing, there's a sort of historical irony here
in that there's a famous objection by this guy named
Krug to basically Hegel and all of his pals,
Fichte Schelling and Hegel, that these guys are just
talking about these complete abstractions.
This is all bullshit.
The this is bullshit reaction to German idealism
has an excellent pedigree.
The number one, the great advocate
of the this is bullshit reaction is Schopenhauer.
Unfortunately for Schopenhauer, his position is just Schelling's.
So Schelling is bullshit.
So when Krug says someplace, I can't remember where he says this.
He says, look, these guys talk about deducing all this stuff
from pure self-conscious, just the concept of knowing.
OK, I'll have you a challenge.
Deduce this pen.
So the idea is that in these systems of German idealism,
we never get to concrete particulars,
that somehow they've erased all particularity or singularity
in these super abstract notions.
So the other irony of such uncertainty
is Hegel is arguing that this, the thing that Krug
is demanding a deduction of, the thing that's
supposed to be the most concrete particular thing possible,
the German idealism could ever grasp
is, in fact, the most abstract, purely.
OK.
Let me just think for a moment how much more I actually
want to say.
OK, questions.
Yes.
I still kind of wonder how those questions tell you something.
It doesn't be like your perception itself
has already information.
It's not like three sides.
Or is it that I have this perception,
but what it says, what it tells, involves
some sort of inner tone, some kind of conceptualization.
So you're asking the question that's
not the question of phenomenology.
You're asking the question, what is perceptual experience?
The question of the phenomenology
is start with shapes of consciousness
and then undermine them internally.
So sensuous certainty, as I said before,
is not as complex as the thing you're taking into it.
It's a philosopher's construct.
It's just immediate sensuous apprehension of intent.
It means, in particular, what it says is a universal.
There were questions for you, Isaac.
Yeah, so is the pure being here, Mass Hegel poet,
is that somewhat similar to Heidegger's being or not?
So Tark and I taught a whole seminar about this.
And I'm not sure what conclusion we came to.
But there's no simple answer to that question.
And insofar as there is one, the answer has to be no.
Because being is what Dasein understands.
And pure being for Hegel has no relationship
to any particular being.
It has to be more general than that.
Yeah.
So if subject is purely receptive,
how do we know the object that we perceive for first time?
Once again, for sensuous certainty,
knowing an object just is apprehending it.
So when you see it for the first time,
you know it as well as you will ever know it,
as well as you know anything.
For the first time, for the second time,
those are only relevant if knowledge is something more
than just apprehending something.
More than just, I mean, and sensuous certainty
has a, when I say apprehension, has a superminable notion
of apprehension.
It's not even the Kantian thing where in apprehension,
you have to combine some.
It's just like, boom, it's before you.
The assumption or the premise implicit in your question
that we know something less well the first time than later,
assume that knowledge is a matter
of accumulating information about something
through further acquaintance with it.
But that is not sense certainty's conception
of what knowledge is.
Sense certainty's conception of knowledge
is in some ways, the more unfamiliar the thing is,
the better.
Because if it's unfamiliar, you're
just going to be like, what is this?
The first time you see a pencil, you don't know it any better
or any worse.
So the subject comes through object?
No.
The subject is immediately sensibly aware of that.
Yeah.
So another question is that, is what conscience means
identifiable to poor consciousness
and what you says identify or is in a cell,
is that identifiable or not really there
to distinct separate, distinct distinct?
I mean, insofar as there's a distinction emerges
between what it says and what it means,
that has to become for consciousness.
Otherwise, it wouldn't be a problem.
All the problems have to be problems that eventually
become for consciousness.
Even if when Hegel originally introduces them,
they're not yet for consciousness but merely for us.
But is what he says identifiable in the cell more like poor?
But what it says, like I said, I don't think
it should be identifiable with it.
Yeah.
Devanj?
What does he mean when he says sublate?
Oh, OK.
I was hoping someone would not ask me that question.
And the reason is, I think, so it's totally
a central in Hegel.
I just think it's easier to understand in the logic
because he has a whole discussion of it in the logic.
So the word in German is aufheben.
Now, aufheben, which is a separable prefix for those of you
who are taking German, has two totally different meanings
in German.
It means both to lift something up, you have this aufgehogen.
It also means to cancel something.
So if you suspend a law, you've heben this auf.
So Hegel loves the fact that there's
this word that means two completely different things.
Now, what he means by it is something
is sublated aufgehogen.
The verb is aufgehben, but the past part is it's aufgehogen.
It's to sublate.
This is sublated.
OK.
So something is sublated when it is canceled but preserved
at a higher logical level.
Now, what does that mean?
What that means, we'll give you some sort of folk examples.
So Hegel likes to say that the British monarch is sublated
in the British Constitution because there's
no monarch, because Charles, whatever his name is,
your king, not mine.
I am a subject of no kings, has no power.
His ancestors would despise his current predicament.
But he's still there.
He's there in a transformed role.
So he's both there and not there.
OK, what does that mean?
I think the better, the way to really answer this
is in the logic.
I think it becomes much clearer in the logic.
But yeah.
So the idea of sublation is that when one shape of consciousness
undermines itself and gives rise to the next,
certain features of the first shape of consciousness
are present in the second shape of consciousness.
But they have a totally different meaning.
They're like the British monarch.
It's a monarch, but in nothing like the original sense.
It's both canceled and lifted in the back.
Yeah, sorry, sorry.
I keep missing you.
Sorry.
Yeah, your name.
Bowie.
OK.
I want to ask about 103, 104, and 105.
That's a lot.
No, no, no.
But just basically, what does Hegel mean
when he says that the whole of the century's consciousness
is its own essence?
Because when he talks about I being its own essence,
I mean, being the essence of the century,
certainly he means that, oh, when I say now, it's my now.
But what does it mean for the whole of the century?
So essence is an essentially contrasted concept.
It's like being special.
If everyone is special, no one is special.
So if both moments of such uncertainty are the essence,
then there's certainly neither of them.
So what that means is it's not that I determine
what the object of knowledge is, or the object
determines what knowledge is.
We're not making these distinctions anymore.
So the move of using the eye to anchor the reference of this
is out, because we're not considering any other of this.
So really, the difference is that sensuous certainty
originally was sort of non-punctual or non- it
was willing to acknowledge that something outside
of a single knowing instance was knowledge.
So you said, well, what about when you were perceiving
the tree rather than the house?
Oh, OK, the answer to that.
Now it just says, I don't know what you're talking about.
That means sensuous certainty, once both subject and object
are equally the essence, which means certainly neither of them
are, that I feel like some of you are still
stuck at that point about everyone's special knowing
is because you're like, but wait,
my third grade teacher told us we were all like,
was she lying to me?
Sorry.
So the idea is, sensuous certainty,
now that we've gotten this revised version of sensuous certainty
that's revised it so in order to resolve these problems,
it knows this.
Now it knows this.
And it knows nothing about that, and doesn't want
to hear anything about that.
And now it knows this.
It doesn't know anything about that, doesn't want to hear about that.
That's the idea.
So it's giving up on any particular privilege in having it.
Yeah.
I'm wondering how exactly is sensuous certainty
is the only conception of knowledge available to itself,
like separate from itself?
Like sensuous certainty can't separate between particular pieces?
Yeah, so good.
So the very idea of a conception of knowledge requires concepts.
Therefore, it has to be able to conceptualize
it's not.
It has to be able to sort of say about itself what knowledge is,
even if that doesn't go in the object of knowledge.
Now the worry here, so we don't want,
so there's two extremes that we want to avoid.
We want to avoid on the one hand what we've been calling caveman's.
It's probably deep into a caveman, I apologize.
Caveman consciousness, where it just knows an object,
doesn't even have a conception of itself in it.
It's probably more like animal consciousness.
On the other hand, we want to avoid a consciousness,
or shape of consciousness, that has a conceptually
or articulate conception of knowledge,
but then doesn't think that that conceptually
or articulate conception of knowledge
is one of the objects of its knowledge,
and can make the following move.
It can say, oh, look, I can explain why the object of my knowledge
is the pencil, rather than the parts of the pencil,
by using concepts.
But the object of my consciousness, the object of my knowledge,
is non-conception.
You see what the problem is?
Because then it could answer Hegel's critique,
while remaining sensuous certainty
in its conception of knowledge.
So the worry is that sensuous certainty can answer Hegel's
criticism by saying, oh, in my conceptually
or articulate account of what knowledge is,
I can explain why my consciousness is consciousness
of this object rather than that object,
even though none of the stuff that I just said
can be among the objects of consciousness.
And so we need a principled reason
for locating sensuous certainty between the skill of caveman
consciousness and the caribdis of overly conceptually
sophisticated sensuous certainty.
And it's possible.
So I said before, one worry that people
have had about sensuous certainty for a long time
is Hegel is making sensuous certainty answer questions
it doesn't have to answer or can't answer.
That's sort of the worry about caveman consciousness.
The worry about what I'm calling conceptually sophisticated
sensuous certainty is it can answer Hegel's critique.
But the material it uses to answer Hegel's critique
doesn't go in the object of consciousness.
It's not one of the things it knows,
or one of the things it's conscious of.
It's meta philosophical, or it's meta epistemological account
of what the object of consciousness is.
So fully defending Hegel would require explaining
our principle way why that is not a legitimate move.
Yes, so far.
Sensuous search.
So who is it fighting with?
That's a phrase to use.
It's some.
OK.
Yeah, it's some.
Yes.
Why can't universality or universality
be known immediately?
This is a sort of, so a universal can't be
known as a universal immediately.
Because to know something as a universal,
you have to distinguish it from a predicament.
So to be conscious of something as a universal,
you have to be aware of it as a one over many.
And that requires us distinct from the many.
But why is it not the other way around?
That you first understand this unity to things
and then you can understand particulars.
Why do we have to understand distinct particulars first
in order to understand what a universal is?
I mean, the same thing.
I didn't say you have to understand the particulars
first.
To understand a particular is a particular.
You also have to understand it as distinct from potentially
other particulars and from universals that it realizes.
So that's also media.
So the immediate, the thing that you know immediately
is this, which now, sensuous certainty doesn't say of it
that it's a universal.
Because it's not aware of it as a universal.
We, the chronological observers, are aware of it as a universal.
Let me ask, how many of you are totally lost?
Raise your hand if you are totally lost.
Someone, OK, there's 0% chance that only three of you
are totally lost.
Just be honest.
OK.
Someone who is totally lost, tell me
the last place in which you were not lost.
Where did you get lost?
Someone we have not heard from yet.
I saw some hands in the background.
Anybody?
OK, Krista.
I'm not sure you're going to be like,
I got lost at this place, which is way further along
than where other people got lost.
So how do we get to pure being and what
sensory sense is pure being?
So the way we get to pure being is, first of all,
we just assume that the object of knowledge is what it is.
You only know what it is.
Now, sensuous certainty is immediate consciousness.
That means what it is conscious of can't be determined.
Because determinacy always involves idiomatic.
That means it cannot be contrast of a particular being.
That means it cannot be conscious of a determinate being,
one being as opposed to another being.
Because to be conscious of one being as opposed to another being,
a determinate being, requires negation, which is a kind of mediation.
That means because it's conscious of what is,
because all knowledge is knowledge of what is,
it's not knowledge of a determinate being,
any determinate being, or even a very indeterminate being.
It's conscious of indeterminate pure being without any determinacy.
So pure being is not a very special being.
It's not the universal being, because that
would be determinate or universal rather than a particular.
It's not God.
It's not the so-called bear particular, because that's
a particular rather than a universal.
It's just being.
It's what Parmenides is talking about.
OK, I'm sorry, I don't know your name.
Did you say you were lost?
Eventually, I didn't get lost.
Do you want to tell me the last place where you were not lost?
Did you trace your steps?
No, I wasn't around the being thing.
OK, that's great.
If you only got lost at being, you're doing very good.
Being is a very respectable place to get lost at.
I got lost the move of using the eye to anchor this.
So the idea is Hegel says, look, here and now are universals,
because that's a here, that's a here, that's a here.
Every time is a now.
Consciousness says, OK, this is a version
of making the indexical move.
It says, here is wherever I am, and now
is whenever I am speaking.
OK, good.
But now notice, I is also a universal or an indexical.
You can say I, I can say I, everyone here can.
I'm assuming everyone here can say I.
That means that for consciousness to use that move,
it has to distinguish its eye from other eyes.
That is just as to say, I, as uttered by any speaker,
S, refers to X. But that requires
the difference between a particular instance
of the variable and the general term binding the variable.
And that's a version of the distinction
between particulars and traversals.
That requires negations.
That's a form of determinacy, and it can't do that.
Is the order a matter of whether Hegel
does time first or space first?
I don't think so.
That's a good question.
But he does time in both cases first, and I'm not sure why.
Yes?
No, you.
Just why can't determination or distinction be given immediately?
Because I feel like I can immediately see differences.
This is a really good question, and it's
totally foundational in Hegel that he doesn't think
that it can be.
Now, for a really good argument, we have not seen one yet.
But the basic idea, it's in a certain way,
it's a version of the Kantian points
that the combination of the manifold
is not given by the senses.
If any immediate form of awareness,
not by means of anything else, does not
acquaint you with anything that's determinate.
Determinately one way rather than another.
For it to be determinately one way rather than another,
you have to be aware of it as determinately one way
rather than the other.
And that means your awareness of it
is that way is mediated by your awareness of the ways
it might otherwise be.
This is so foundational for Hegel.
I'm not even sure he ever argued sort of.
An immediate relation is a relation
to something indeterminate.
And that means all of the immediate stuff.
So people in this period love appealing
to immediate awareness of things.
And the Hegelian move repeated over and over
is that makes the object of your awareness totally indeterminate.
OK, now here's a challenging question.
Is any of this in sensual certainty a criticism of Kant?
Does Kant have to disagree with any of any in sensual certainty?
You want to take a stab at it?
There might be a way in which if you read Kant's definition
of intuition at the beginning, that this is just
an attack on that conception, that you can be immediately
related to the object.
OK, so on one way of thinking about this,
this is a criticism of Kant's notion of intuition.
Because intuition is an immediate relation.
And Kant thinks it's an immediate relation
to a determinate object.
That's the intuition of this object rather than another.
But you could also think Kant completely
agrees that in order for you to be conscious of your intuition
as being of one object rather than another,
you have to conceptualize it.
So it's not at all clear that Kant
has to disagree with it like this.
So let me just repeat that line of thought very briefly.
So one reading of Kant, which I don't think
is a right reading but simply upheld,
is that intuitions, because they are immediate,
are completely indeterminate.
The object of intuition without concept is just totally indeterminate.
I think that doesn't make any sense in Kant.
But if that's what Kant's view, then Hegel's just making his point forward.
I think it's much more plausible that Kant thinks that intuition
is an intuition of a determinate object.
It's a particular object.
It's an intuition of this object.
It's not just an intuition of objects that are indeterminate.
But Kant can, I think, acknowledge the point here by saying, oh, that's right.
But in order for you to be conscious of that object of intuition
as the object of that intuition, you need to conceptualize it.
Yes?
Yeah.
Just one question about that last comparison between the two
that you made.
It seems to me when you're talking about the object for Hegel,
that seems much more broad than the object for Kant.
I think we would grant that the object does need
to fall under concepts for Kant.
But it seems like there are things that when Kant wouldn't consider an object,
but you suggest that Hegel maybe would.
And that would seem to maybe.
So object at this point is supposed to be totally general.
It's the object of consciousness.
The only more specific notion of object that we've seen
is the object of sensuous certainty.
And that's quite determinate.
It's intended to be a very determinate conception of an object.
Something you can be sensuously certain of.
You can't be sensuously certain of God.
You can't be sensuously certain of the laws of nature.
You don't sense them.
You can't be sensuously certain of propositions inside of it.
So we can see the most general possible notion of object at all,
and an attempt at a highly determinate one, where the highly
determinate one has Hegel or he's fate.
I'm tempted to think that Kant would just say everything even concepts
are immediate because of self-consciousness.
So then there's no real problem for him that, for example,
to think that we can't immediately know what universal means.
Because everything's kind of immediate.
Sorry, did you say immediate or immediate?
Immediate.
But Kant's conceptual representation is immediate representation.
To have a concept is to represent something
by means of the marks of that concept.
So conceptual representation, as such, is immediate.
What about just unity of app perception, the baseline?
Is that kind of immediate?
And from there, you can just know how things are like?
So I'm immediately conscious of myself as combining.
But in order for me to be conscious of anything,
something has to be given to me in tuition.
And I have to conceptualize it.
So you're right, I'm immediately conscious of myself as acting.
But what Hegel would say is that I is totally indeterminate.
That's kind of the point.
It's totally empty.
The I has no content.
So Hegel would actually think that, on that point,
Kant completely agrees with it.
But I'm worried that we're kind of losing everybody with Kant.
Yes, sorry.
Just one more comment.
Great.
I think it was all met.
Is there an issue with Hegel's specific case in time
as you adrift with it or not?
Yes.
Depending on how strongly, it depends on what
Hegel means by calling space and time universal.
I think all he means by universal is a one over met.
And in that very minimal sense, space and time
are ones over many in Kant.
They're not conceptual universals.
But yeah, that's a good question.
I guess you repeat your indexical formulation
of the universality of the I.
Oh, absolutely.
I would love to do that.
OK.
Or any speaker S I has uttered by mass refers to S.
Seems unarguable.
What did you learn today in philosophy class?
Well, we learned whenever anyone says I, I refers to them,
the person who said it.
How much is the tuition of the school is?
So the idea is notice that this requires
a difference between the universal speaker
and individual values of this variable.
If we wrote this out, it would start with the quantifiable
clause for all S. If S is a speaker,
and that just has contained within it
the difference between a particular and a universal,
that involves mediation, it involves determinacy.
None of that can be in the content of what
sensuous certainty is conscious of.
Now, the question that I was talking about before
is whether it could be something sensuous certainty could
say in order to explain the reference of its consciousness
to an object, even though it's not something it's conscious of.
And that gets into the difficult question of,
how conceptually sophisticated are we
allowed to make sensuous certainty?
Willow, you have your head up.
No, he's got 109.
OK.
I understood.
Or are you going to ask me the series of Vakas?
I mean, if you want to add it to it.
You have to ask me.
Sure, sure.
Well, what are they?
I just read off the bad.
Well, they're Roman gods.
You know that.
There you go.
Yes, I do know that.
OK.
That's not what I would do.
What I was curious about, anyway, was the so I understood you
as saying that sensuous sort of, you know,
says it knows pure being, but really knows
this specific thing, this pencil, whatever.
And then it's an issue that you can't know pure being
through your senses and whatnot.
Where does that come from?
You know, you can't know it through your senses.
That does seem obvious to me, but would this have to be given?
So it doesn't come up here, such as the series of Vakas passage.
So it was a response to a worry that you might have.
Hegel is assuming that by having demonstrated
that what sensuous certainty can say of its object,
namely that it's pure being, cannot be
what it means to be its object.
But then why couldn't sensuous certainty just
say, this is a question that as far as I know,
Hegel doesn't address, that, oh, no, no.
That's both what I said and what I meant to be my object.
The object of sensuous certainty is pure being.
And he doesn't address this.
Now then you might say, well, OK, how could sensibility,
how could the senses acquaint you with pure being?
But now I will talk about series in Vakas.
So this is a great passage.
With its appeal to universal experience,
we may be participating to anticipate concerns
in the practical sense.
So the phenomenology is not just about theoretical knowledge,
it's also about practical knowledge, knowledgeable is good.
In this respect, what one can say
to those who make assertions about the truth and reality
of sensuous objects is that they should be sent back
to the most elementary school of wisdom,
namely to the old Ellucidian secrets of Ceres and Vakas.
So the Ellucidian mysteries are this mystery cult
in ancient Greece that you would be inducted into,
and you would be taught various cosmic truths
about the universe that we don't know that much about it.
But Hegel knows as much as anyone in the 19th century
other than Schelling about classical antiquity.
And he has a view about what the esoteric doctrine, the insider
teaching of the Ellucidian mystery cult was.
And he's about to tell us what is.
And they have yet to learn the secret of the eating of the bread
and drinking of the wine.
This is so because the person who has been initiated into these secrets
not only comes to doubt the being of sensuous things,
but rather it arrives at despair about them.
In part, he brings about their nothingness.
And in part, he seems them to seize them to do it to themselves.
So what Hegel is referencing is the fact that on his view,
what you learned in the Ellucidian mysteries
was that no individual being has any reality.
And you learned this by basically taking a lot of drugs.
I'm totally serious.
This is almost certainly true.
Almost certainly true of all these ancient mystery
cults were based on the heavy use of all this magic.
That's like you can actually prove this archaeologically
because you can get plant residue from these various bowls
and you can figure out what psychedelics they use.
You take a bunch of psychedelics, and then they would perform
these little pageants for you.
And then the point on Hegel's interpretation,
the point of the pageant was to discover
that no finite being has any reality.
The only being that's real is pure being.
So the point is the people who insist
on the reality of individual things, the sensuous certainty
person, needs to go do the Ellucidian mysteries.
And what they'll see is that's the true result of their view,
that the only thing that's real is pure being.
Now what are the animals excluded from this wisdom?
Instead, they prove themselves to be
the most deeply initiated into it,
for they do not stand still in the face of sensuous things
as if those things existed in themselves.
Despairing of the reality of those things
and in the total certainty of the nullity of those things,
they without any further ado simply
help themselves to them and devour them.
Just like the animals, all of nature
celebrates these revealed mysteries,
which teach the truth about sensuous things.
So Hegel is saying, even the animals know better
than the sensuous certainty person,
they know that finite things don't have any reality
because you can just eat them.
So is that just a joke?
It's not just a joke.
Because Hegel's view, Hegel's true view,
he's not someone who believes that the only thing that's
real is pure being.
That view is called a cosmose.
It's the view that denies the existence of the cosmos,
where we take the cosmos to mean determinate beings,
determinate or find ideas.
So if an atheist is someone who denies the existence of God,
and a cosmist is someone who denies the existence of beings,
there's only pure being.
Now Hegel, I'm sort of obsessed with this.
Some of you heard me talk about this many, many times.
This is one of my great hobby horses.
Hegel is obsessed with refuting a cosmose.
In fact, the science of logic, in a less temperate moment,
I would say Hegel's entire philosophical project
consists in the reputation of a cosmose.
That's a little bit of an exaggeration.
But his view about the North, so Hegel
does not think that the Eleusinian mysteries are
getting you at the truth.
Namely, all there is is pure being and finite things
have no reality.
He thinks that view is incoherent.
Because if they have no finite reality,
how could you have thought they had a finite reality?
The illusory being is a kind of being.
So they can't not exist at all.
And furthermore, he thinks that the pressure to a cosmism
is endemic or internal, more or less,
to the entire Western philosophical tradition.
In fact, Western philosophy begins with a cosmism.
It begins with Parnedians.
And it returns in the form of Spinoza,
he thinks Spinoza, although he Spinoza denies it,
Spinoza's view entails that no finite things exist.
In fact, not just no finite things, no beings exist.
God is not a being.
God is just pure being.
That's what Hegel thinks Western is.
He's also read it.
And he thinks that his entire philosophical tradition,
fifth de Chale, all of his pals, also
have this problem that their fundamental first principle,
the I or the indifference point, actually
eliminates the existence of all finite things.
It eliminates all beings.
It's just pure being.
So what we have to do is maintain
the existence of finite things, but not in this dumb way
that sexual certainty wants to.
Here's a being, here's another being,
and they're unrelated to one another.
In fact, the way we have to retain
the being of finite things is the way the animals do,
which is to say, they have a, finite things
have a kind of being, which is then subrelated,
but then retained at a higher level.
So we'll talk about this in the logic,
but the digestive model of the animal's relationship
to finite things is, in fact, Hegel's
view about the reality of finite things.
So what he's saying is, you need to go
to the L.O. studio of mysteries, or more properly,
just to pay attention to animals.
And what you'll see is, finite things do have a kind of being.
Then we'll read some more.
Actually, in the back, we have not heard from you.
Yeah, sorry.
So then, where does, I guess, Hegel's one time student,
Sterner fall out?
I have no idea.
I've never read any Sterner, because it just
sounds so insane.
Generally, so after Hegel's death,
or even during Hegel's life, people
divide in their reactions to Hegel
between so-called left Hegelians, who
think that the true philosophical message of Hegel
is revolutionary with respect to traditional religion
in the Prussian state.
Right Hegelians, who think Hegel is a defender
of orthodox Lutheranism, and the Prussian monarchy,
and the true view.
Central Hegelianism, Hegel was a central Hegelian, namely
that the true religious concept of Hegel
is not very much like orthodox Lutheranism,
but nor is it any kind of atheism,
or this Freudian nonsense about how
God is the projection of our inferiority complex,
or whatever.
And the political content of Hegelian philosophy
is a constitutional reform of the Prussian monarchy,
rather than it's in its absolutist form.
But I have not gotten into this.
Sterner is one of the big left Hegelians,
but I have, to a large extent, not really gotten
to the left Hegelianism, because they
don't feel like I understand Hegel well enough to get
into the left, right, and center Hegelianism.
OK, but before we finish today, I
want to talk about the end of 110, or actually 110.
However, those who set up such assertions in lines
with the previous remarks also immediately
say the opposite of what they mean,
a phenomenon that is perhaps best
able to bring them to reflect on the nature
of the century with certainty.
They speak of the existence of external objects,
which, to put it more precisely, can
be turned into the actual, absolutely singular,
individual, wholly personal, individual things, each of which
is absolutely unlike the others.
This existence is said to have absolute certainty and truth.
They mean this piece of paper on which I am writing,
or rather have written this.
But they do not say what they mean.
They intend to talk about concrete, sensible particulars,
but what they really say is universals.
However much they actually wanted to say what they
knew about this piece of paper, and however much they wanted
to say it, still it would be impossible
because the sensuous this, which is what is meant,
is inaccessible to the language which belongs to consciousness,
or to what is in itself universal.
In the actual attempt to say it, in itself
would therefore rot away.
So the singular, an individual, is inaccessible to the language
of consciousness because, to refer to this,
you need not just a universal, nor do you
need just a singular indexical like this.
You need both.
You need to refer to this pencil.
You need to have a conception of the object
as an instance of a universal.
So the idea is, if you just have this,
there's no account of why you're referring to the pencil
rather than the parts of the pencil, the eraser, the tip.
The only way objects can be available for consciousness
is if they are this such, an instance of a universal.
Skipping a bit, if nothing is more said of a thing,
that it is an actual thing, an external object,
that it is only expressed as the most universal of all.
And what is therefore expressed is the sameness with everything
rather than its distinctiveness.
If I say a singular thing, then instead I
say something entirely universal about it,
for everything is a singular thing.
Likewise, this thing is anything one pleases.
To characterize it more precisely as this piece of paper,
every and each bit of paper is a this, a piece of paper,
and I've only spoken, as usual, of the universal.
That is to say, I need not just a universal, but something
like a Kantian intuition.
However, if I wish to lend a helping hand to speech,
which itself has the defined nature of immediately inverting
the meaning, that of making it to something else,
and in that way of not letting the meaning get
into words at all.
So this is what Hegel loves these plays on language,
because he thinks what language shows
is this distinction between what consciousness means to say
and what it says.
Then by pointing out this piece of paper,
I thus learn from experience what the truth of sensuous
certainty, in fact, is.
I point it out as a hearer, which
is a hearer of other hearers, for which in its own self
is a simple ensemble of many hearers, which is to say,
is a universal.
In that way, I receive it as it is in truth,
and instead of noting what is immediate, I perceive.
So now what Hegel is doing is transitioning
to the transition from the first object to the second.
So that is to say, from the first form of consciousness
to the second form of consciousness.
The second form of consciousness is the determinant negation
of the first form of consciousness.
We don't have a new beginning.
We don't start from nothing.
Nor is the second shape of consciousness just,
you don't know it.
The second object is the being of the first object
for consciousness.
So insofar as the first object knew something,
the second object is what it knew.
So insofar as the first shape of consciousness knew something
or intended to know something, it was this.
But the reason it couldn't know this
is because it didn't put any universals in the shape,
in the object of its knowledge.
So the resolution of that problem
is to recognize that the object of knowledge
is a thing that instantiates universals,
a thing with properties, of this such.
Because once we have that, we have both of this,
which is something like a spatio-temporal indexical.
It indicates a direction in your environment.
But then with the concept, it picks out
in the fortunate case which thing in your environment
you're referring to.
If I say, this book, I'm screwed.
If I say, this iPhone, now I'm good to go.
And the reason that worked is because I
didn't say the iPhone or iPhones.
That will refer to all iPhones whatsoever.
Nor did I say this, because this doesn't determinately
refer to anything.
I said, this iPhone.
And that only picks out this if this is an iPhone,
and not everything else is an iPhone, which
means this has to have a universal,
has to be an instance of something,
and it has to be a universal that other things don't have,
not everything else has.
Otherwise, it wouldn't pick it up.
Yeah?
For instance, expressing it as an actual thing
and its sameness with everything else,
does this, when you speak to the students,
be that Schelling position that you
emphasize in the practice of managing the 12,000
by a computer-socially-centered student?
Yes.
In an other way, if we want to bring Schelling into that,
what he's saying is what sensuous certainty means
to know, what it intends to know,
is concrete particulars.
What it actually says it knows is
something as indeterminate as Schelling's note in which
all cows are alive.
Pure be.
Now, that brings in Schelling, but many of you
don't know who Schelling is.
Don't worry about it.
But the first principle of Schelling's philosophy,
Hegel thinks is, actually Schelling explicitly says this,
is as indeterminate as purity.
That's to say, it has no differences or determinacies
in it whatsoever.
It's completely a cosmos starting point.
So what Hegel is saying is that sensuous certainty thinks
it's the most concrete empiricist position
possible.
But what it's actually saying is that what it's conscious of
is the most insane Schellingian totally
indifferent starting point of all philosophy.
So that means that the second shape of consciousness
is one in which objects are instances of universals, things
with problems.
Now, I just want to note that if we
look at the table of contents of the phenomenology of spirit,
I think this edition has a relatively informative one.
We'll just note that the first form of consciousness
is sensuous certainty.
The second shape of consciousness is perceiving.
And the third shape of consciousness
is force and the understanding, appearance,
and the super sensible world.
So if we think of this in Kantian terms,
and then the second one is self-consciousness,
we're in a certain way building up
the capacities of the Kantian mind.
There's appearance, perception, and then understanding.
Where understanding involves making a distinction
between how things appear to you and the super sensible objects
that are appearing to you.
And then there's aperceptive self-consciousness.
Now, that doesn't mean that this is supposed
to correspond one-to-one with Kant's taxonomy
of the human mind because Hegel thinks of Kant
as he thinks of every other philosopher
as insufficiently systematic.
That's to say, we don't want a one-to-one correspondence
with Kant's quote unquote system because Kant's system isn't
really systematic.
This is the systematic articulation
of everything that has to be in spirit in order
for spirit to be spirit.
But even properly, it maybe isn't that
because it's doing that by way of uncovering
the internal dialectical failures of all
of these other conceptions of what now it is.
Yeah.
I have a question similar to Kantian's one.
And it's just about concepts.
I feel like in the Cartesian sense,
the thoughts in itself themselves
are kind of immediate to us.
And then with perceptual input, we see new things.
And we maybe we can modify all those concepts and so on.
It's like backwards.
So that is a remark in a different way
of doing philosophy, a way of doing philosophy in which we
start with what seems plausible to us,
and then we reason from there.
That's not what Hegel is doing.
That's not how the phenomenology works.
The phenomenology does not work with any.
Our assumptions are supposed to be completely suspended.
And it's supposed to unfold from the most immediate,
that is to say, indeterminate shape of knowledge possible,
everything that knowledge is.
So what seems to us plausible isn't,
so to speak, argumentatively relevant.
And so likewise, what's phenomenologically available
to us in Dufcerlian sense also isn't relevant,
because that would assume a different conception
of what knowledge is, which hasn't been dialectically
unfolded yet in phenomenology.
Yeah.
In the previous lecture, you said
that each shape of consciousness
has to determine the next shape of consciousness.
It seems like pure consciousness has options
between sticking to its original claim.
I know particulars.
Or just going into pure being.
How about an issue?
It is an issue.
The systematic structure of phenomenology
requires that there be one and only one successor
shape of consciousness.
If there's forking paths, then the argument is real.
So if we really want to take phenomenology seriously,
we have to ask ourselves at every step,
is there a potential forking path here?
And the move towards pure being is one such forking path.
Now, I think Hegel thinks he has a number of reasons
to foreclose sensuous certainty of pure being
as a possibility, one of which will be relevant when we talk
about pure being and logic, is I think
he thinks pure being is not a possible object of knowledge
because it's so indeterminate.
You can't know pure being.
What would you know?
What did you learn at school today, pure being?
Oh, tell me about that.
It is.
It is just purely.
Is there any particular way?
Oh, no, no, no.
It's not any particular way.
It just did.
Yes, fine.
Each of the arguments Hegel makes,
are those supposedly the only arguments that
can be made to move from one argument to the next?
Good question.
I don't think Hegel wants to like,
we don't want to read Hegel as having some like,
implausible view or like, these words in exactly this order
have to be written this way.
So like, there has to be some flexibility or plasticity
in the order of presentation.
Like, did he have to do this whole thing of doing,
now is night, and here's the tree, here's the house.
I see the tree.
I see the house as someone else.
Couldn't he have just skipped immediately
to the form of sensuous certainty
in which there's no essential difference,
no difference in essence between subject and object?
Probably.
But the problems arise from the shape of consciousness itself,
and therefore, they cannot be Hegel's invention.
So I'll just warn, I mean, one of the reasons
I don't love teaching the phenomenology of spirit
as the whole book, I actually love
teaching sensuous certainty because people get the point.
And you can actually kind of philosophically engage with it,
pretty straightforwardly.
One of the reasons I don't love teaching the whole book is,
the further you go in the book, the harder it is to believe
all of the transitions are principled.
So famously, as a friend of mine, I put it this way,
it's more or less impossible to predict
what the next shape of consciousness is going to be,
which is a sign that there is not, in fact,
a principal function that takes you from shape of consciousness
n to n plus 1, because then we would just learn the function.
Every time I read the phenomenology,
I'm a little surprised by what comes next.
I'm like, really?
Why that?
Likewise, it's hard by the end of the book
to feel like all of these problems are purely interned.
My general sense is, I kind of feel
like I have a line on what's going on everything up
through reason.
And then the transition, once we transition
to spirit in the middle of the book,
the feeling of arbitrariness in the successor
shapes of consciousness and the problems that arise
starts to just kind of grow exponentially.
So after we get to reason, we get to spirit.
And the first shape of spirit is this shape of spirit
in which somehow your family is in touch
with the gods of the underworld.
But then in your public life, you're
like a good patriotic Greek citizen.
So it's just like, what?
Why are we talking about antigone?
It's just very hard for me to really be convinced
about every transition.
I'm not a super phenomenology optimist.
Just to make sure I got this, however,
the paradox of sense certainty is not
being able to say what it means or the contradiction to what
it means when it says, are the rocks on which sense certainty
as a shape of knowing, for example.
And that's what causes the despair, is it,
that lifts us up to the next?
Exactly.
Up to the next state.
And that's an example of an internal self-contradiction.
Or imminent, yeah.
Could not the advocate of sense certainty
say that contradiction is not part of its bag
and that therefore what's being advanced against it
is actually an external criteria?
Good.
Gets to a fundamental issue in Hegel's philosophy.
Why do we have to care about contradictions?
Foundational, if we just read the way the book works,
it seems absolutely foundational that contradictions are death.
That means you get a contradiction,
you have to overcome it.
Sense to a certainty cannot just rest content.
Just be like, yep, I know this object.
That object is not knowable.
What's the problem?
Now, this will be more relevant in the science of logic.
But Hegel's, both the phenomenology and the science
of logic, mostly explicitly, I kind of think actually
the entire encyclopedia, the entire system,
depends on uncovering and reconciling contradictions.
Now, that's true, as you just brought out,
from the word one of the phenomenology.
It will also be true from word one of the science of logic.
Now, no justification is given to us.
So that means it's internal, it's foundational for Hegel,
that you cannot just rest content with a contradiction.
You have to move beyond.
Now, that means that a certain kind of attitude
towards the principle of contradiction
is built into the way the whole philosophical system works.
One view about contradictions is that contradictions cannot even
be thought.
You can say P and not P, but you haven't thought anything.
Kant can be read as saying that.
Another view is that you just shouldn't
believe contradictions, you shouldn't think of them.
You can, but you shouldn't give them.
Kant can also be read that way.
The problem with the don't do it is, OK,
I do a lot of things I shouldn't do.
What's so bad about contradicting myself?
What I say won't be true, but I also
say a lot of things aren't true.
The problem with that you can't think it is, well,
it does seem like we think contradictions all the time.
You can reason with them.
So now Hegel definitely is not a you cannot think a contradiction
person, because the logic is just full of contradictions.
And it's all thinking.
But nor is he merely a don't do it, because that's too weak.
And the logic is not built on, oh, you should keep doing this.
The forward movement of the phenomenology and the logic
are not a normative one.
You're a bad person if you don't keep reading.
So he seems to have a third view, which is contradictions
are thinkable, but thought as such must strive to resolve.
It cannot rest content with a contradiction.
It has to try to go beyond the contradiction.
And the reason this is relevant is because there
are people who read, so we'll talk about this when we get
to the logic, there are people who
think there are true contradictions.
They're called dialytheists, because they
think something can be both true and false.
That can be true, that p is both true and false.
And Hegel is one of their main historical supports.
You can read Hegel as a dialytheist,
because he says dialytheist friendly things all the time.
The problem is if Hegel thinks that contradictions are true,
when we get to contradictions, why do we have to move beyond them?
The problem with the dialytheist is
they don't have a sufficient, for Hegel,
a sufficiently strong justification of why we,
when we get to a contradiction, we don't just go, oh,
interesting fact, contradiction.
What they will say is you want to minimize contradictions,
because the more contradictions you have,
the more messed up your logic is.
So the basic idea of dialytheist logic
is you can have a non-trivial logic that
has true contradictions in it.
You just have various logical methods
of constraining, localizing the contradictions.
So there's a contradictory subject matter here,
but as long as you're sufficiently far away
from that subject matter, you don't have to contradict yourself.
But the problem is that involves a basically pragmatic approach
to logic, which is totally acceptable in contemporary
philosophy, but it's totally an alphabet of Hegel's whole way
of doing philosophy.
What we're trying to do in hand-making philosophy
is not like, find the best overall plausible view
compatible with our starting positions.
No.
We're trying to totally systematically
from a completely indeterminate presuppositionless starting
point unfold all the philosophy.
So we need a more systematic explanation
of why, when we get to a contradiction,
we're not just happy with that.
And I mean, this is a very huge topic in Hegel.
It will occupy us at various points
over the course of the semester.
I think it's just internal that Hegel's conception
is that thinking strives to overcome a contradiction,
and thinking is not in agreement with itself.
It's not fully thinking, except insofar as it
overcomes contradiction.
OK.
I think that is going to be it for today.
I'll set some reading notes for next week.
There's a lot of reading on the syllabus for next week.
It'll take me two weeks to get through all of it,
try to read absolute knowing, and then experience gratitude.
We're not reading the whole phenomenology.
Yeah.
We'll go back.
We'll read the whole phenomenology.
Yeah.
I think it's good.
It's good.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes.
Thank you.
Thank you for showing questions.
Oh, OK.
One, two, three.
OK.
Mr. Brown said that it's OK.
Thank you.
It's not that it's OK.
It's OK.
Yeah.
Yes.
It's not really about politics anymore.
It's about transformation.
Yeah.
We'll just do it on the conference.
There you go.
Yeah.
Good.
Thank you.
We have your photos of it.
OK.
Thank you.
You're out of the park.
No, we're not in the park.
Oh, my family's not here.
Hello.